alex je comprends pas pourquoi tu es là
en fait j'ai besoin de papier nous
voulons nous a manqué en forêt aussi on
m'avait manqué
il t'a dit pourquoi ils étaient là
qu'est ce qui t'a raconté tu lui as
parlé demandé des nouvelles de catch it
a démandé quoi exactement au sujet de ta
soeur alex va partir avec 4,6 à vue à
chercher pourquoi
comme mon fils est parti on a dit qu'on
effacer l'ardoisé souvient équivalent
gamin la météo c'est mon neveu
comment je vais expliquer que le mec qui
a tué son père est en vie du pech bouge
pas
j'avais peur et vous perdre tu l'aurais
tous les c j'ai tout lâché pour sauver
la pauvre tu quittes avis la lettre
qu'ils sont prêts à faire des courses
pour te retrouver
c'est quoi cette histoire tout sur ce
mec qu'est ce qu'il fout là
frei pour qui ces consignes affaire de
famille tu me laisses rsa - d'accord il
faut que tu parles aux enfants et l'or
qui tue les héros il faut leur dire la
vérité je voulais vous protéger de la
haine c'est pourquoi donc sur vous gm a
donc les cartes flash ball a bouclé
toutes ces années j'ai perdu ma gueule
pour que personne ne sache toujours su
ce qu'il fallait pour tout le monde
encore une fois je suis parti c'est ça
vine mensonge ne trouve pas d'issue tu
dis que c'est trop tard et puis même la
vérité ap les deux sens
mais pas uniquement patat
et rien pour moi